[Music]
in new parenting news Oh are we
considered new parents yes okay
how many years until you're considered
old parents is it it's not your age it's
the kids age right I think maybe after
they're toddlers yeah that's why I'm
like dang it everyone always knows my
age if they just calculate Isaac's age
what's wrong with that
thank you an old ma you always say the
age yeah you're still young - but you're
younger the kids all it's an old mom
yeah that's what no cuz you're saying if
you're calculating by your kids age yeah
so he's 10 technically that would make
me an old parent than right yeah yeah
don't makes you a young parent
definitely old mom you like we're new
parents you're a parent you're young old
you know an old yes
young young old I want to be an old
parent I am new and old I wanna be a
[ __ ] bedroom well if you have like
five kids and then the youngest one is
one you're not a new parent still yep I
sure another chance
oh so true yeah math submitted bile in
it yo dad it's under submitted it
alright head the Thunder Thunder Thunder
that's how you supposed to he's too cool
for ours at the end mm-hmm he Apes you
Andy [ __ ] these kids [ __ ] that whole new
mom over there
Ryder gives advice on how to raise a
happy kid in the digital age
take those liners giving advice you
don't be funny to have any kids yeah
they don't have no [ __ ] joke no way
there's no way he doesn't if he does
they're like 40 but I would like to hear
this because I feel like every
generation the prior generation never
understands them and I feel like because
my parents didn't understand me I
probably won't understand Tiger as
open-minded as I think I am I probably
will be extremely close minded to him do
you think things are gonna be as night
as day as our generation though like
even some of us are a little bit
different age we're still and they're
like our [ __ ] was literally like almost
from like vinyl you're probably gonna
think we're not a day
they're gonna be like dad you grew up in
a generation where there's only two
genders you [ __ ] him black and white
mother Wow because we're still in the
middle of that like like where we're at
is like dead middle I feel like I don't
think we'll see that much of a chance
analog to digital world yeah we
literally came from like what blows my
mind is people still today remember like
when cars came out yeah like there's
still people alive yeah there's still
people live man yeah that's that's gonna
be us we're gonna be the ones I remember
when Internet came out and then having
floating cars and [ __ ] yeah I mean like
I guess in our generation we're gonna be
the ones that's to remember when
FaceTime and [ __ ] was the first you know
when I first came out yeah touchscreen
that's what thanks kids I think our
things are more exponential than they're
gonna be yeah cuz everything even now
that's new is based off the internet and
we're in the Internet and we made that
[ __ ] Wow so we're very unique I think so
okay I think you'll be able to relate to
your kids better than like our
grandparents give raise to us like our
grandparents can't a [ __ ] phone that
you can I competitive relate to the
people that work for me at Barba some of
their jokes that they say I'm like I
don't even know what you're you're just
so out of and Instagram I'm like yo
Nadine
alright [ __ ] doing a story thing
again deal and I got to put the link to
swipe up what do I do
that's you but we got a click here do
this I don't know I think I think it's
more of like a cultural group thing
we're like subcultures and stuff that
you stay kind of with your age range and
then hop cultures like younger and stuff
like that so so for example there are
like older professors that are in their
60s 70s or whatever word they might not
completely connect but at least they get
it yeah they're always around so many
like young folks you know we're like us
we haven't been in college for like the
last what 10 years or some [ __ ] and then
we're past that
and we only hang out around people our
age and then it just keeps getting older
and older yeah my mom taught high school
for 20 years and she was like no new
before I can't like she was way cooler
little garbage bag [ __ ] little garbage
bag
did you watch to be amazed there's like
12 rappers that came out I don't [ __ ]
any of them are I'm like I was deep into
like EDC when I go-go dance for them as
[ __ ] and now I was like who the [ __ ] are
these DJ's like I'm just a look at the
lineup what trips me out is seeing
youtubers at the VMAs and like like
legit celebrities like they're walking
the carpet these tips here to raise a
happy kid in the digital age first one
is get gritty grits
the combination of perseverance and
resilience that helps you bounce back
from disappointments plays an important
role in well being so at school online
and with friends kids feel pressure to
achieve something on the first try
instead instill what is called a growth
mindset the process of trying failing
and learning from mistakes when they
feel defeated their inner voice will say
you got it that's like every generation
is like [ __ ] about the younger one like
our [ __ ] great grandparents like
Great Depression style is like talking
[ __ ] about our grandparents and
grandparents talking [ __ ] about our
parents you had refrigerators every
generation saying the younger ones
aren't [ __ ] tough enough or they're
not like patient enough is like food
that's because you're like 60 and you
have all these years to be patient and
learn that [ __ ] you [ __ ] forgot what
impatient [ __ ] you were yeah next one
nourish their sense of self-worth
self-worth likes comments and other
indicators of online status are part of
kids social media lives but there's a
tipping point when a kid's perfectly
natural curiosity about what others
think about them turns into a heart
harmful fixation on peer validation that
causes depression you can help your kid
against this by fostering an internal
sense of self-worth
that one's Roth dude that one's hard I
think it's hard without the internet
that's hard for even more people are you
know super I think you
that's still hard kid feel cooler like
especially Bibi himself and still feel
like advice here has encouraged
activities and hobbies that help give
kids a sense of accomplishment on their
own terms
Southall is gonna say skill building and
controlling things it helps people build
confidence like controlling your own
body controlling your own mind yeah and
then people that can start building a
skill they can see the effects of their
efforts being rewarded by you know
people saying like oh that was a great
job that was dope and all this stuff and
doing that there's value and what they
do for them seeing it themselves
look at how you literally make something
you see like well no this was a piece of
wood and now it's a [ __ ] table that
you should encourage children instead of
saying oh my god you're so smart you
should tell them oh my god you're such a
hard worker instead because if they
they're smart they're just really okay
I'm just gonna slide with like I'm
obviously naturally smart and talented
and then meet other people and realize
no not really and they don't know what
to do with themselves so to encourage
hard-working like you know that's true
cuz I met a lot of smart [ __ ] that
are lazy as [ __ ] and they don't do
anything cuz I think everything should
be handed to mindset mm-hmm
next one be grateful being aware and
thankful as a tried and true life hack
that leads to a stronger sense of
well-being you can actually use media
and tech to cultivate a sense of
gratitude
like there's sites and apps that you can
let your kids check out to help but
teach them to make gratitude is one of
those hard-ass things though cuz I think
all of us remember like our parents
bitching about some [ __ ] where you're
not grateful or whatever right and then
some [ __ ] happens to you thirty years
later and you were like oh I am grateful
now yeah you got to experience it with
technology now what I would do is sit my
kid down and watch him watch one of
those sad videos a third-world country
kids don't know don't worry though know
you got a gold day I feel like it is
I'll work for you don't work for me
because like when I don't have empathy
though that's why
like okay because like I what am I still
to this day one of the things that
whenever I'm having a bad day or I'm
like depressed or my friends whatever I
just think of or I tell them like think
of the small things you have a bed you
have a warm home you just ate a meal you
get your phone you have internet stuff
like that and I keep that in mind at all
times like that makes me way luckier
than a really big part of the world did
work for me I'd watch these videos was
like holy [ __ ] I'll never complain again
I think I'm really bad it was one time
he was complaining you don't want to
drink the like water mm-hmm and I was
like you know there's kids I don't even
have access to clean water and I was
showing him like photos and videos damn
that's true cuz it seeing that might be
way crazier cuz I remember my parents
saying like there's kids in Africa and
all these countries that don't get to
eat every day and I'm all like okay and
then I started grabbing all the food and
I was like I can't finish my meal but
maybe you could mail it to them I
thought I was making sense yeah yeah I
don't know the boot could go bad so fast
I was just like well you know like my
parents give food to homeless people and
stuff so I'm like well let's ship it to
them yeah cuz they're for me I'm like
I'm full and I don't want this like like
I can't even eat anymore
like give it to them you know those uh
those shows or TV shows or over or
videos that like really spoiled rotten
kids they were just pieces of [ __ ] like
there's one recently where a kid was
pulleys grandmother's hair a Chinese
kids yeah a toy right I want to take all
those kids and like ship them to a third
world country and just let them see it
and live it you know and then make it a
reality show because I want to watch the
reaction so bad I want myself like
survival parents to a different Island
to teach them how to be better parents
because I don't want that came out with
the other Island could just be Bart's
mom Oh kind of like
yes that's a great idea gives her some
perfect I read this I read this quote
saying that if you don't if you raise
your kids right oh if you raise our kids
right and your kids right then they'll
raise your grandchildren if you raise a
kid wrong then you'll have to raise
their grandchildren damn I'm just trying
to raise myself right right now all
right next one is go outside nature is
scientifically proven to boost
well-being if your new inspirations
watch nature videos or download apps and
encourage outdoor exploration or just
you know put the phone down
close the laptop turn the TV and go it's
so funny it's like if you need
inspiration to go outside watch some
videos of outside for just a while
instead of just closing it in then
walking outside sometimes I just go out
put my [ __ ] hand on a tree and lean
[ __ ] branch and see that [ __ ] [ __ ]
blowing in the wind and I study that
leaf and it [ __ ] clears my mind man
you heard of grounding no what is that
oh yeah yeah when your energy is yeah I
heard it I talked about I picture it
like the blue avatar movie where like
energy is rolling through the ground
which it is it's at some extent and how
far you want to believe all that by its
really it's really about putting your
feet in dirt or walking barefoot in real
dirt leaves etc I do that all the time
that's good for you in LA I might step
on a syringe though so maybe not yeah
you got a drive up my Beach
I love doing that the beach yeah it's
like energy it's not even just like the
feeling or sensation she's like real
energy so I kind of like Sun and vitamin
D type stuff yeah yeah all right last
one here is foster connection so it's
pretty much as finding a balance between
screen time and home life I actually
face-to-face talking with their kids you
know have certain restrictions on like
the amount that they they actually have
I need this one dude he's so weird
he had like two friends like in person
in real life right next to him and then
he wanted to hang out with the online
person on Twitch that was weird
not weird because they're supposed to
foster realize well flew in from a
different place yeah to hang out with
this right [ __ ] does [ __ ] like I don't
understand hypothetically look I'm
sitting on the couch the airplane
whatever tell you no no I'm just saying
hypothetically bro I'm just saying
hypothetically look you know maybe this
happened twelve hours ago I was doing a
little bit of work on my laptop just
hanging out I was playing music I was
playing some like skinny asian girl like
you know tease me I'm trying to get I'm
trying to get tyka involved in some
really good music I'm playing some bill
there's a fourth bro can talk twice
Stevie Wonder planned though weathers
playing playing the music of love matter
people something weird yeah we're jammin
and I'm doing a little bit of work am i
answering emails I'm currently trying to
buy a house so I'm doing all these
things and then I also just had twitch
on not that big a deal
not that big of a deal all right that's
weird nope not that big of a deal my
story
me and Jill we're sitting right next to
him like literally this far no no
they're on the ground they're on the
ground looking at I 2 I and this fault
is watching the twitch of someone else
we're real people this is a fake person
to talking like 3 out 3,000 other people
right now oh my girls I'm talking to
friends
you're a [ __ ] weird they had the TV
on I feel like it's the same thing yeah
don't blame me
oh we're you're the TV on
[Music]